Evan can you sing us a little acapella
okay Fly Me to the Moon I want to dance
Among the Stars I want to see what
spring is like on Jupiter and Mars he's
gonna Buzz the [ __ ] out of that imagine
being asked to like perform like a
monkey and still get in the boot that's
crazy couldn't be me bro I'll show us a
little dance move how about you suck my
nuts yeah
wow like X Factor this is an X Factor
this is average Factor you want to go on
a date with me this is fuzz Factor I'm a
little chubby you trying to go on like
come on bro get him out of here how are
you doing today I'm good it's this is
okay okay future okay this is my future
and blade had a baby this is like future
and blade were in [ __ ] Canada in
February and had a baby
[Laughter]
uh what's up
this is wild bro this is this is this is
Canada Miguel this guy looks like a
square and this guy looks like he
doesn't know what shapes are
like one person's geometry one's just
like I'm vibing like it's so different
this is nerve-wracking yeah same there's
nothing to be nervous about
there's everything to be nervous about
yeah true bro that hairdo is killing me
bro they look like the loafer thing that
I got in mind
it really do you imagine instead of
using a loofah my man is just like this
hey babe come here let me wash your back
but it's good hair it's good hair them
glasses are triggering the [ __ ] out yeah
anyway my name is Cease I'm quavion nice
to meet you nice to meet you too I love
your outfit thank you honestly I think I
like yours a lot more I want to take
these off but I smoked a lot of weed
stop come on
this is gay as hell yeah whoa
it is a sickness
it is deviant
I want to take these off but I smoked a
lot of weed stop come on
I'm so sorry
damn damn is right he's so adorable but
I feel like he's a baby but not your
baby but not my baby
let's go get it yeah so what's up
um having a good day I'm over
caffeinated same yeah for sure are you
like an oat milk person like that oh
you're a Trope why do queer people love
oat milk so much I do not understand I
will drink oat milk okay okay but okay
bye it was nice meeting you bye button
was it the oat milk listen I'm a black
ice coffee person honestly me too
this is like so extra
this is so extra
I want to be Rancher what's up with Camp
what camp
you know when they talk about gays in
Camp no I don't know what the [ __ ] you
so campers like the set of behaviors
that are like stereotypically gay which
a lot of folks and they say like oh you
get it from Camp like that like they all
went to the same camp okay so it's a
term that's using the geek what I don't
know much about it I was going to ask
you you know more than me I feel like
you like your fit for this episode
apparently you know camp and I don't so
who's fit oh listen I just think that
you're pretending not to know but hey
cool I really don't listen I understand
you got the bandana on today you know
what I mean you're really trying to
fight that and it's cool did you go to
that I just want to let you know I'm
supportive Price lgbtq Plus all that
stuff you know what I mean put the p in
there for preach whatever how are you
I'm good I like for sure thank you I
call it my party shirt
last night all right that girl again
she's back
oh sorry oh it didn't turn red yet no
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
tell me about yourself okay I'm
Gabrielle
give each other a chance yeah let's give
each other a chance let's let's Okay I
do see you as a friend though no she's
back she's about to take another L she's
she's on this episode she's gonna Buzz
this one no I think he's gonna I don't
know it just makes me feel like a
middle-aged lesbian on a cruise tell me
more about your tattoos did this one
hurt it did hurt yes but it was worth it
I want a tattoo but I have to wait on my
sister I'm a twin by the way I'm a twin
oh
oh my bad my apologies I might have been
your sister uh and so you might be just
catching a straight because your sister
was acting stupid so my apologies I'll
hold that down or it's a family thing
and they all stupid or maybe if mom
maybe that's the bot maybe maybe what
that's so amazing okay this is crazy are
you too close with your twin very close
like we talk like all the time for sure
what about you and your twin she's my
best friend she's I'm like her hype
person what is your last serious
relationship
um
seriously you looked away it's been a
while like some years so not even a
whole face what is a whole face if
somebody is cute and they think you're
cute you just are you a hoe I am a
full-blown hoe what about you so like
I'm in the process of it right now
you're in your office yeah I am and
twins hashtag hashtag no twins look now
people online but not call us that
though are you two sexually attracted to
each other I I see you as a great friend
a great friend it does run to the family
he's at a great friend okay bye [ __ ]
hit that button bro yeah I would like
rock with you you could be my best
friend
I'm Tate what's your name I'm Carter you
know like Hobbies what are you what's
your flavor and she's the girl who did
the
she hit the button she went
oh mate wow man you're
it's possible and then she got broken
and she had her heart broken by the
skinny Asian lady something like that
okay that's her they're all back
now listen whenever I see someone I
never hit the face yeah I can see that
where they take a big ol you make sure I
[ __ ] frame it in my room and put it
on the picture I remember that remember
when we had that yeah there's a wall of
L somewhere in here you guys will get to
see it one day um well clearly I like to
get tattooed I have my like matching
cats I have my cat mermaid
and then I have a lion and then I have
like a bunch of others
this guy just went cataloging his whole
[ __ ] tattoos
but it's just us it's the topics as well
yeah cat mermaid matching cat oh nobody
crazy cat lady ain't nobody
thank you
you are eliminated why did you reject
hate sometimes it's hard if you don't
get like an instant connection it's hard
to just like be like yeah let's go on a
date you can't force anything man I get
that on to the next date yeah I would
like to meet somebody else what's up man
I'm good I [ __ ] with your shirt heavy
that's cool too thanks I'm Carter I'm
Emil nice to meet you Emil nice to meet
you I love your um dress Etc yeah it is
a dress it is that's a propeller on you
thank you Camille what are you looking
for in a partner
me
the roller coasters
you do yeah I want to love them I mean
if you just want to like watch me go on
one that's fine we can still go to the
fair that would be cool yeah yeah I mean
are you attracted to Carter
[Music]
a little yeah what yeah
Carter do you think Emil's a cutie yeah
of course I mean you're super cute you
caught my mind yes yo this I like
[Music]
here if you sit on my face I want the
fat of a suffocate me I hear
I ain't mad at that live your life bro I
ain't mad at that
if you have no sense of humor and if you
don't think I'm funny then we're just
probably not gonna get along I'm
definitely not funny that's okay I can
be funny enough for the both of us yeah
what's your perfect first date I mean a
picnic would be cute but I don't I don't
really go on dates at all so any kind of
date is my ideal date he went perfect
I'm broke
[Laughter]
coffee
got that because look at me do I look
employed
this dude like he looks like he just got
done
taking off his Joker makeup because for
some reason there's like a big smudge on
that I left yeah yeah it's just
something about him just seemed a little
bit unstable he was a dude with the
wheelies yeah yeah sorry my bad I like
where this is going kill the Sparks I
one more time and if neither of you hit
me I think we've got a second Fate on
our hands
Emil Carter congratulations you have won
the button
my dude got that serial killer face
well you know girls like if you don't
feel dangerous okay so he's dangerous
but I'm in like I'm in a safe space with
him I mean letting that girl sit on your
face is definitely the definition of
danger so you know shout outs to him
shout outs to that it's good to see a
big girl win every now and then build
your neck bruh you'll be fine
I don't think there's any buildings
but shout outs to them you know uh good
for them either you want to add no shout
outs to you yeah let us know what you
guys think in the comments below